welcome everybody it is so great to be
back here today we have so much to talk
about first let me explain what happened
last week now understandably
last week i was gone and understandably
many people assumed
reasonably so that this was part of my
paternity leave me being gone last week
it was not i was um
suddenly in an emergency fashion
temporarily a single dad last week and
ended up having to bail on the entire
week uh let me tell you what's going on
so as many of you know
had a baby uh some weeks ago
and took about 10 days off initially and
then slowly kind of worked back into
doing the show but limiting my other
stuff with the idea that
once the baby is an age in a couple
months where she's no longer sleeping
all day then i would take some other
time off and and whatever but in the
meantime wanted to get back to hosting
and just kind of a little bit of a sense
of normality and last sunday night i was
ready to wake up monday and do the show
when at uh 3 am
my girlfriend wakes me up and says um
sir i'm not feeling well she doesn't
really call me sir but okay she said i'm
not feeling well um can we take my blood
pressure with um postpartum moms you
monitor for something called postpartum
preeclampsia and one of the signs of
that is high blood pressure and uh we
take her blood pressure this is 3 a.m
take her blood pressure
blood pressure's fine
305 she says i'm i'm just really like my
abdomen just hurts i'm not feeling well
and we're thinking that's weird all
right let's let's call the ob the
obstetrician their on-call line and see
what they say
by 3 10 in the morning she's really not
feeling well
and by 3 15
she's doubled over on our couch
um at this point i'm saying what what is
this this this doesn't seem good
um my girlfriend has a really high pain
tolerance normally like during the
during the birth
she asked you know when would people
normally start like getting anesthesia
and the nurses said oh 24 hours ago most
people would have had anesthesia she was
like this really isn't that bad so when
she's doubled over i know something
something bad is going on
uh by by 3 20 in the morning she says
you got to call 9-1-1 and at this point
i know it's bad i call 9-1-1 um and she
is just
in such abdominal pain that she's unable
to move 3 30 in the morning
ambulance shows up
and she's rushed to the hospital and
says
take care of the baby
so all of a sudden i am saying
i gotta make formula uh i need to figure
out what's going on
long story short by about 11 in the
morning about eight hours into the er
stay um they figure out that she has
a um duodenum perforation the duodenum
is uh sort of like between it's below
the stomach but above the next thing i
guess it would be like the small
intestine i think there's a perforation
there and we're thinking what what are
the odds young woman
healthy
all of a sudden a perforation that it's
just so unlikely
and what we find out and of course with
these things you never know a hundred
percent but what the surgeon and the ob
what everybody agreed upon is
this is a rare but known side effect of
a significant use of ibuprofen ibuprofen
well why
after the c-section she was put on um
ibuprofen both in the hospital and then
after the fact every six hours that's a
lot of ibuprofen and this is sometimes
you get an ulcer from ibuprofen use you
can have gastritis
and every once in a while
you get a perforation
and this was that rare case this is it's
a really serious condition there
sometimes uh postpartum perforations
in other countries in different
situations lead to death
and so um she was rushed into surgery
it's a relatively simple surgery but
with very kind of intense complicated uh
recovery including not being able to eat
or drink anything for five days which is
a form of psychological torture so
that's why i was gone last week i was
going between the hospital
and um uh taking care of a baby
initially by myself and eventually we
got help from family and it was crazy i
mean i don't you know there's a million
different details i could give you about
uh how
how
hot difficult situations are in
hospitals even in good hospitals
and um
you know also the realization of like
how do single moms do it you know when
we just randomly hear
oh barack obama was raised by a single
mom oh all right like
the day-to-day of that you know once you
get down to the logistics once you get
down to the specifics of what that is
it's incredible it it really is
and um i was always a supporter of all
you know funding and and programs to
help parents in general and single
parents and all i am doubly or tripoli
now a supporter after having experienced
it
um for a week particularly knowing very
little about babies i have to say
so
fortunately now
everybody's on the mend it is like a
four to six week recovery period in
total but uh things have gotten much
much better
and everybody's reunited i'm no longer
doing the single dad thing but um and
and by the way the other thing
single parents who work i mean this was
a this was a particularly acute
situation right where my girlfriend's in
the hospital and i'm home with a baby
and etc but
there
there's no way i could have worked i
mean it's just impossible right i was
doing the pediatrician appointments
managing the feeding
coordinating help with the family that
was able to help you
there it was it's literally 24 7.
um and uh
i just i just don't even know i don't
even know how i could have possibly done
any job and i'm lucky enough to have a
job where i'm the boss and i can say
well i'm off for the week and of course
we had we had great villains we had luke
beesley and we had pat and we had pharyn
and we had the resources to do that but
imagine that number one i had an
employer saying you know we start at 9
15 where are you and it's like oh i i
can't make it for a week i can barely
leave
the one room in my house where i'm doing
things um but imagine also that i
my income went to zero as a result of
that as many people don't have paid time
off
uh or sick time or whatever the case may
be so
incredibly eye opening and horrifying
but hopefully now
on the up and up and of course we've got
a monitor for
complications and sometimes after when
you have various tubes inside of you for
a week
when they remove the tubes
you've got to watch what happens and
you've got to watch for infection and
all of these different things so we're
not completely out of the woods yet but
it's so great to have a little bit of a
sense of normality and to be back on the
show today but that was last week it was
not really paternity leave in a sense it
was in that it was connected to the
birth
and uh interestingly that this was
the the ob team
that was part of everything even though
this was not an ob related uh procedure
the ob team was was involved in
everything they said
our entire practice is now changing how
we do
uh postpartum advil we used to do it
what's called prn the patient just
requests it when they feel they need it
and then they often wouldn't and then
they'd wake up and they'd be in pain so
we would uh just just do it
every six hours and we're not going to
do that anymore so crazy situation
good to be back
one of our sponsors is airly the
delicious crunchy crackers that are
fighting climate change did you know
over 25 percent of greenhouse gases come
from the global
food supply chain a lot of companies
talk about getting to net zero carbon
emissions by 2030 or whatever date airli
has been net zero since day one and they
will never be a net carbon emitter each
box of airlie crackers removes 18 to 21
grams of co2 from the air that's why
it's called airlie they're available in
four delicious sweet or savory flavors
cheddar sea salt chocolate salted
caramel or caramel as some people like
to say whole grain oats are always the
main ingredient they're made with 100
real cheese cocoa butter brown sugar our
whole team loves them i know you will
too it is a snack you can feel good
about go to early foods dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman for 25
off the link is down below